[Music]
on this Thursday night cabinet ministers
grilled about foreign meddling you said
repeatedly unequivocally but you had no
information plus why that conservative
MP was asked to apologize and the
investigation into alleged Chinese
police stations in Quebec Fox News Under
Fire again even from Republicans I think
it's both
the lawsuit exposing the Network's inner
turmoil and what private texts from its
hosts reveal
athletes take Aim Canada Soccer treats
the women's game as an afterthought the
skepticism pay Equity can be achieved
and comedy in a time of need people
saying that you know we really help them
the dynamic duo of indigenous women
delighting crowds
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
are more developments on foreign
interference tonight the RCMP is
investigating what they suspect are two
so-called police stations in Quebec
covert centers police suspect are
working on behalf of the Chinese
government it's believed Beijing has set
up more than 100 of these around the
world to monitor harass and in some
cases repatriate Chinese citizens living
abroad the mounties say they are working
to detect and disrupt what they call
foreign state-backed criminal activities
at these sites
but what we know is that the Chinese
Community has voiced their concern some
people are being threatened some people
are being intimidated and we certainly
need their cooperation in order to
further our investigation
the RCMP would not confirm the exact
locations of the centers under
investigation but did say one is in
Montreal the other in brassard a suburb
on the city's South Shore last year the
RCMP revealed its investigating four
other so-called Chinese police stations
one in Richmond BC and three in the
Toronto area
as well today the federal foreign
affairs minister testified at a
parliamentary committee and she
confirmed a Chinese political operative
hoping to work at the Chinese Embassy in
Ottawa was refused entry to the country
but things got a little heated at this
hearing Mackenzie gray is in Ottawa and
has our top story tonight Mackenzie well
Donna it was another contentious day on
Parliament Hill as the committee looking
into foreign election interference saw
delays by the Liberals and personal and
political attacks from the conservatives
you were you didn't know anything in
December and I just finished my sentence
please Michael well grilled by
opposition MPS the foreign affairs
minister admitted she was kept in the
dark about alleged Chinese electoral
interference how is it that the Global
Mail and local news have information but
you as Minister of Foreign Affairs know
nothing when it comes to activities of
foreign actors in the country the
foreign affairs minister was not meant
aware and since then I've made sure that
that changed the government did make its
concerns over electoral interference
known when the Chinese Ambassador was
summoned in February but one step the
government hasn't taken expelling any
Chinese diplomats who were involved with
the alleged meddling instead Melanie
Jolie says the government took the
easier path by recently barring a
Chinese Envoy from coming to Canada when
China wanted to send a political
operative last fall we decided to deny a
Visa Jolie added she raised these
concerns with her Chinese counterpart
appoint conservative MP Michael Cooper
seized on uh you've talked tough with
your Beijing counterparts so you say you
even stared into his eyes I'm sure he
was very intimidated Cooper's comments
sparking outrage from the opposition I
think it's shameful that that was even
said in this place yeah there's a lot of
things around this place that make me
puke in my mouth often the condemnation
of Cooper came after the committee had
been meeting for over four hours the
majority of that time used up by liberal
MPS filibustering to avoid a vote on
having the prime minister's Chief of
Staff Katie Telford appear at the
committee mass shooting inquiry one
liberal used her time to suggest that a
public inquiry into alleged interference
would be too costly referencing the
review Into the Nova Scotia mass
shooting that cost 25.6 million dollars
so I can only imagine what this public
inquiry is going to cost the taxpayer on
top of the house committee the National
Security and intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians announced it accepted
the prime minister's request to have the
group of nine MPS with top-level
security clearances also study foreign
interference Donna okay Mackenzie gray
and Ottawa thanks for an interference
was also in sharp focus in Washington
today as the United States top
intelligence official delivered her
annual Global threat assessment the
People's Republic of China which is
increasingly challenging the United
States economically technologically
politically and militarily around the
world remains our unparalleled priority
the CCP represents both the leading and
most consequential threat to U.S
national security and Leadership
globally
that is American National Intelligence
director Avril Haynes her threat report
largely focused on China she cited
beijing's growing cooperation with
Moscow and its continued push to become
the preeminent power Haynes says
president XI jinping's government is
increasingly convinced it can only
achieve its goals at the expense of the
U.S and other Western Nations
a multi-billion dollar defamation
lawsuit against Fox News is pulling the
curtain on the inner turmoil at the
conservative cable news station Dominion
voting systems of voting machine company
is suing Fox for repeating Donald
Trump's lie that the 2020 election was
fraudulent it turns out not only does
the Channel's most popular host Tucker
Carlson not believe it was stolen text
messages reveal he hates Trump with a
passion Jackson prosco on the
embarrassing details emerging in this
lawsuit
the most watched cable news channel in
America finds itself making headlines we
need to find out exactly what happened
in this election after a week that
revealed top stars at Fox News pushed
lies about the 2020 election even as
they privately admitted what they were
saying on air was false we saw blatant
election law violations in state after
State the revelations came as part of a
1.6 billion dollar defamation suit
against Fox News launched by Dominion
voting systems we talked about the
Dominion software I know that there were
voting irregularities Dominion was the
target of extensive conspiracy theories
about voting machines after Trump
refused to concede the election
President Trump is zeroing in on
Dominion voting machines according to
internal emails and text messages
obtained as part of the lawsuit Fox's
Prime Time hosts privately mocked Trump
and his advisors as Liars while Fox
chairman Rupert Murdoch expressed
concern about what his hosts were saying
on air in one on earth text message
Primetime host Tucker Carlson said a
former president Trump I hate him
passionately Fox News has called
Dominion's lawsuit a distortion and an
effort to smear the company yet even
away from the courts foxes continued
attempts to prop up former president
Donald Trump have caused serious harm to
the Network's reputation these were not
insurrectionists they were sightseers
this week Carlson aired new footage of
the January 6th attack on the U.S
Capitol
released to him by Republican speaker of
the how house Kevin McCarthy thousands
of hours of tape were selectively edited
an attempt to rewrite history they're
not destroying the capital they
obviously Revere the capital even for
Republicans it was a bridge too far I
think it's [__] insiders describe
the turmoil as an existential crisis for
Fox I think fox has abdicated
being accepted and treated as legitimate
news organization what fox has been
doing is inventing
falsehoods or adopting falseins that
were invented by others in this
precarious moment the one story the
network refuses to cover is its own
Sheltering its loyal audience from any
news about Fox News
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
there's been another train derailment in
the U.S involving a Norfolk Southern
Train about 30 cars came off the tracks
in Alabama there were no reports of
injuries or leaks Norfolk Southern has a
history of accidents and this morning
the company's president and CEO was
asked if he would commit to fully
cleaning up the toxic spill from last
month's train derailment in East
Palestine Ohio
I want to begin today by expressing how
deeply sorry
I am for the impact this derailment has
had on the residents of East Palestine
and the surrounding communities Norfolk
Southern will claim the site safely
thoroughly and with urgency
you have my personal commitment
people there have reported health issues
such as rashes and difficulty breathing
since rail cars carrying Vinyl chloride
derailed and burned last month
now to Ukraine Russia launched a huge
wave of missile and drone strikes today
hitting residential buildings and
critical infrastructure right across the
country at least six people were killed
hundreds of thousands are without heat
and electricity and the nuclear power
plant in zapparesia was knocked offline
again raising the alarm once more about
a nuclear catastrophe Crystal gomancing
Reports
by hand rubble and bits of metals likely
debris from a missile are cleared away
in hopes of finding survivors but the
black bags appear
my second sister called me and said that
a rocket hit our other sister's home
she's hopeful but knows her relatives
are likely dead for the most part the
leviv oblast in Western Ukraine has been
spared from deadly strikes
Russia however Unleashed a barrage of
countrywide missile and drone attacks it
says hit Ukrainian military sites and
Energy locations supplying the military
retaliation says Moscow for an armed
attack in a Russian border Village
allegedly by opponents of Vladimir Putin
fighting for Ukraine this is the sixth
time
that this operation nuclear power plant
has lost all of sight power the main
line that supplies power to cool
reactors at Europe's largest nuclear
power plant was knocked offline for
several hours the nuclear Watchdog
agency which has employees at the site
has been trying to get both sides to
agree to a safety zone for months to no
avail one day our luck will run out in
the strikes Russia says its use Kindle
Hypersonic missiles Kendall means dagger
they can carry nuclear materials and are
hard to detect by air defense systems
the West has to supply Ukraine with
everything it needs for example the
fighter jets it needs to supply long
range weapons so that Ukraine can strike
legitimate military targets within
Russia and thirdly
influential States like India and Israel
should get off the fence and help
support Ukraine so far there have been
no announcements about providing Ukraine
with fighter jets or changing the rules
around donated weapons allowing Ukraine
to strike outside of its territory
Ukraine's president addressed the deadly
strikes saying everyone is working
together to ensure the invincibility of
Ukraine
Donna all right crystal thanks German
police say several people are dead and a
number of others injured after a
shooting in the city of Hamburg
Germany's interior Minister says special
forces were deployed along with a large
number of police it happened at a
building in the city's ulsterdorf area
local media identified it as a Jehovah's
Witness Center Police say the gunman is
believed to be among the Dead
the federal government in Canada is
proposing changes to terrorism laws
allowing Aid workers in Afghanistan to
do their jobs in areas controlled by
terrorists without being prosecuted for
contributing to a terror group and I
want to be clear that stringent measures
to prevent any financing from reaching
terrorist groups like the Taliban will
remain in place
but we will not let these laws stand in
the way of doing the right thing
since the taliban's take over
humanitarian groups have been warned
buying goods or hiring locals would
involve paying taxes to the Taliban
under the changes organizations can get
an exemption provided they prove the
benefits outweigh the risk of Terror
groups interfering with their work
coming up the pandemic's effect on our
Mental Health
members of Canada's women's national
soccer team took their fight for equal
and equal playing field to Parliament
today giving powerful testimony about
the ongoing dispute over pay equity and
budget cuts at Canada Soccer and the
culture of the governing body
I've never been more insulted than I was
by Canada soccer's own President Nick
bontes last year as we met with him to
discuss our concerns
I was tasked with outlining our
compensation ask on behalf of the
women's national team
president of Canada Soccer listened to
what I had to say and then later in the
meeting referred back to it as quote
what was it Christine was questioning
about
Nick bontes resigned last week
acknowledging a change was needed at the
top of Canada Soccer and today as the
women's team testified Canada Soccer
released details of its proposed
collective bargaining agreement
revealing both men and women will be
paid the same amount per match and that
both will have an equal share in
competition prize money
the pandemic's lingering effects are
everywhere from the economy to mental
health early on when there was such a
lack of knowledge about covid-19 it was
feared there would be a Cascade of
depression and anxiety that could last
for years but Canadian researchers
suggest on average people are more
resilient than we thought Catherine Ward
explains
we all know someone who struggled or
multiple people struggle with mental
health
if you could rewind time
who knows what's going on at this point
do you remember how it felt throughout
the pandemic it's frustrating
we finally thought we'd get our senior
year the roller coaster I hope the 2022
is a hell of a lot better than 2021
because that was terrible of skepticism
and despair it's
can't be worse hope and acceptance I'd
say realistically cautious covid-19 took
a toll however new research suggests the
extent of its effect on global mental
health might be relatively limited
during much of the pandemic you know
people have have assumed that there
would be a you know a tsunami was a word
that was used a mental health
catastrophes a canadian-led research
team went through 137 studies from
around the world that tracked mental
health indicators before and during the
pandemic for the most part things either
had not changed or had changed minimally
as human beings we're very resilient
however the study does note women have
struggled more which comes as no
surprise to clinical psychologist Kathy
kamkar certainly a lot of straws and
then also hoping to be able to to manage
it all sometimes day's a tendency to
engage in self-criticism or wanting to
be a better person or a better mother or
did this feeling of failure the lead
author notes there are some
informational gaps they are still
looking to fill we had data on
adolescence but virtually none on
children so Under 12 years old we also
didn't have data on people like
those who are working in Elder Care or
medical care still the team believes
this study highlights how when the chips
were down people came together we helped
each other along the way to prevent
having some of those struggles and that
you know we can do this we need to keep
on keeping on Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
future flooding ahead what's being done
to mitigate rising sea levels in Canada
[Music]
the changing climate has long been
viewed by countries around the world as
a looming threat to National Security in
a newly released analysis Canada's
intelligence agency ceases warns global
warming poses a profound and ongoing
threat to National Security and
prosperity including the loss of parts
of British Columbia and Atlantic
provinces because of rising sea levels
tonight Alicia drows takes a look at
what's being done to protect Coastal
communities
foreign
the rise of sea level is far from a
perfect science but based on decades
worth of data researchers have created
models projecting scenarios up to 2100.
that's in space of 80 80 years is giving
you a a sea level rise of one meter for
the high CO2 scenario for the low CO2
scenario it's more like half a meter I
New Brunswick border the rising level is
a big concern projections have suggested
that the shingnecto ismus which is home
to the main transportation Corridor
between the two provinces is at risk of
being flooded by 2100 but the real worry
is that flooding could actually be an
issue much sooner if there's a a
hurricane during a high tide when the
moon is full we will get a flood and
that flood will be extremely damaging
three projects are being considered to
protect the area all focusing on
reinforcing the dike system but once a
project is chosen it will take 10 years
to complete time we may not have a storm
of a lifetime is now an annual event in
Atlantic Canada NBC 80 percent of the
population lives within five kilometers
of the shoreline there's people living
in in the floodplain that might be
directly impacted but we're also seeing
food security potentially at risk in
2021 significant rainfall led to severe
flooding in Abbotsford can killing
hundreds of thousands of farm animals
while dikes and sea walls are often used
to help protect such areas landscape
architect case lockman says relocation
may be better to allow for more
environmentally Sustainable Solutions
there's flood resilient crops and
traditions are transitioned to flood
secure food production we could think
about aquaculture or other types of
food security elements that could work
with water lachman says it's important
to take steps now because while
incremental sea level rise may not
always be noticeable disaster could
strike at any time Alicia dross Global
News Amherst Nova Scotia
comedy duo next to indigenous women
having allowed to help their community
[Music]
we all know how laughter can lift us
even help us heal while there are a
couple of women in BC who have teamed up
to bring humor to their community and
they're quickly gaining popularity
through social media nitu garcha has
their story
lifelong friends with natural Talent
foreign
making people laugh by being themselves
they have Prince and Winnie Sam describe
themselves as dirty old grannies do you
have any jokes you'd like to share with
me right now I don't know if it's
appropriate for their content not always
suitable for younger fans if I were a
drum he'd bang me oh my God
they're from nakaliwata Nation near Fort
St James in northern BC how do you
decide what you're going to record I
think we just we just wing it we just
wing it yeah and they gave themselves
traditional titles I'm gonna name myself
Suga
then two seconds later Bev goes I want
to name myself lilit so we're milking
sugar the names represent the great
combination they make but really the
work was born out of a need for healing
it's a like a survival skill sometimes
people saying that you know we really
helped them because they were in the
darkest place of their lives and they
they ran into a clip of our videos and
it just brought them out to return the
joy they bring others members of their
Community raised enough money to help
the duo achieve their dream to fly to
Vancouver for a Canucks game later this
month we're gonna go and um hopefully
get on the big screen the jumbo screen
and maybe they'll see a little bit of
lip swinging their hips like they got no
bone it's sure to be quite the show they
hope leaves people laughing and with a
meaningful message if you really need
someone just phone a friend and to just
keep laughing
Global News
well they'd be a riot to hang out with
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Castle Mountain in Banff
Alberta thanks for watching Nita will be
here at the anchor desk tomorrow and
I'll see you on Saturday for the new
reality bye-bye
[Music]